سيشارك محققون هواة أجانب في نهاية هذا الأسبوع من
جميع أنحاء العالم فيما يطلق عليه
المنظمون أكبر عملية
منسقة لمطاردة الوحوش منذ عقود في
واحدة من أكثر بحيرات
لوخ نيس الأسطورية في العالم. وسيراقب المشاركون
أدلة من مواقع استراتيجية على
ضفاف البحيرات الاسكتلندية بينما
سيشاهد الآخرون بثًا مباشرًا من المنزل في
بحث ضخم عن دليل على
وجود وحش بحيرة لوخ نيس الأسطوري، ويُطلق على هذا
الجهد الضخم اسم "
البحث" ربما على اسم فيلم تم إنتاجه عام 1986 عن
مهمة صبي للعثور على وحش بحيرة أسطوري، وهو
أسوأ فيلم على الإطلاق بالمناسبة.
هل سيجدون أي شيء، هل
ستعيش أسطورة البحيرة القديمة هل أنا الشخص الوحيد
الذي شاهد المهمة بالفعل؟ الوقت الوحيد هو الذي
سيحدد ما إذا كان سيتم الإجابة على هذه الأسئلة المقنعة أم لا